mon l'une des conséquences directes
c'est l'augmentation de la dette puisque
on considère que vesoul est une ville
surendettée puisqu'il vous voudrez 14
années pour vous désendetter
est-ce que vesoul est une ville qui vit
au dessus de ses moyens vous savez le
problème de la dette ça fait quinze ans
que frédéric bernabé nous dit qu'on est
en banqueroute l'année suivante
or on continue à investir pour vesoul
une ville qui est endetté est une ville
qui investit effectivement entre 2000 et
2010 nous avons beaucoup investi avec
alain joyandet ge l'assument nouveau
théâtre nouveau stade de foot passage à
niveau il fallait remettre à niveau de
la ville de vesoul est donc s'endetter
pour investir mais vous disais 2010
c'était il ya dix ans et cette dette
elle existe et nous la remboursons sans
aucun problème puisque nous remboursons
des emprunts qui était à 3 4% et nous en
prenons maintenant à 0 8%
oui mais loyal d'habitants plus la dette
par habitant augmente le nom verte mais
c'est marginal
ce qui compte c'est si on peut
rembourser la dette et on avait besoin
de l'art en bourse alors est ce que
l'amérique bernabé vesoul est elle au
bord de la banqueroute
vesoul et en énorme difficulté je
reviens un petit juste une petite
parenthèse sur tout à l'heure il ya
aussi la disparition des services
publics dans notre ville qui est une
ville tertiaire qui a aussi augmenté la
démographie mais sur la dette sur la
tête c'est très simple c'est c'est
mécanique
une baisse de population là évidemment
elle gonfle par habitant derrière ça des
choix notamment hasardeuse avec des
emprunts toxiques en 2008 ou 10 millions
d'euros d'emprunts à 25% à la sortie
aujourd'hui
heureusement que l'état donne 325 1000
euros par an sur 14 ans 15 l'hélice la
mêlée la règle et nous quand même on
paye toujours cette d'état donc
aujourd'hui moi je pense qu'après il ya
la baisse des dotations et ses acquis
aussi fait que on a moins de ressources
mais l'essentiel aujourd'hui la dette
elle est là comment faire pour inverser
la tendance pour moi il y un vrai défi
c'est reconquérir de la population gagne
et de la population
sinon nous n'y arriverons pas et nous
serons dans une spirale de déclin comme
malheureusement d'autres villes ici
encore alors sur les finances et sur
comment faire venir de la population à
vesoul
j'ai déjà un peu répondu sur comment
faire venir de la population sur les
finances
je rappelle que nous sommes la 31e ville
la plus endettée de france dette qui ne
baisse pas du tout contrairement à ce
que vous dites
elle ne baisse pas puisque nous
remboursons tous les ans toujours sur la
même sur les quinze ans et réemprunter
même à un taux très faible pour encore
rembourser cette dette c'est être
surendettés ça le prouve bien
alors moi je dis qu'il ya des économies
à faire on nous demande à tous de faire
des économies on dit à nos habitants
fait des économies et bien nous allons
faire en tout cas c'est ce que je
propose sur quoi je tiens je vais vous
le dire moi je vais vous trouvez de
l'argent faut en trouver dans la halle
enveloppe dis lui que je baisserais de
2,50 m as assez marginal sur le budget
d'une vague ginals à millions d'euros
sur un mandat vous pouvez faire un
million de asud économie si vous baisez
non je vais tomber l'euro on n'est pas
la maison de madame aubry c'est 1% des
dépenses de fonctionnement que ce que
vous faites des 99 autres c'est une
vraie question
mais en tout cas vous n'avez pas trouvé
la solution jusque là ce que je propose
également ca dans les économies à
effectuer et bien c'est de poursuivre
ses économies en sueur tout simplement
les frais de fonctionnement
pas de cabinet pour le maire je suis pas
là pour qu'on fasse briller
je suis là pour faire briller ma ville
figurez vous et un cabinet qui coûte
cher ça peut aller jusqu'à 3 millions
d'euros sur le mandat je vous trouve 4
millions en u en deux minutes
je pense qu'il faut un peu se pencher
sur le fonctionnement général de la
ville et celle là je crois qu'il y a des
vraies économies à réaliser
maintenant je suis d'accord avec
frédéric bernabé la population doit
revenir j'ai répondu comment faire pour
faire venir cette population à vesoul
mais en tout cas ce qui est embêtant
quand même dans cette dette
c'est que l'investissement est faible
une ville qui a investi est une ville
mois construit endettés dont acte mais
une ville qui investit ça se voit vous
avez des grues vous avez dit ça bouge
chez nous ça ne bouge pas et elle
investit
l'investissement est a minima alors j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne vit pas dans la
même ville on parle de deux grues hui
chez des grilles en a eu des logements
construits en centre ville y en a eu
je pense au foyer aubry 42 logements
construits entre le raisin sereine elle
rue de l'aigle noir l'ancien site de
l'hôpital près de 150 logements sont
sortis de terre il y à quelques quelques
mois seulement
donc j'ai l'impression quand j'entends
mais mes collègues qu'on ne dit pas dans
la même ville